[Music]
one man who's been vocal on this side of
the channel
in his criticism of the government's
approach is jonathan assumption
he's a former supreme court judge he
joins us now
uh jonathan samson welcome to spectator
tv
morning um do you
not have any sympathy with the
government on its slow approach to
coming out of
the lockdown which you could defend as a
a better safe than sorry approach well
the government's position throughout
right from
last march has been that it will not
discriminate
between people according to their
different levels of vulnerability
so it has locked down healthy people
and young people who are at very small
risk of getting
seriously ill let alone dying and it has
adhered to that
throughout what we are seeing now is
that
an even bigger anomaly about this
approach because with
more than a third of the population
vaccinated including
a very high proportion of all the most
vulnerable people
they are still saying that everybody has
got to be
treated in exactly the same way whether
they are vulnerable to this disease
or not i think we are now reaching the
stage
when people are going to start losing
patients with this
it's clear that there is a third wave
about
we see that most of all in continental
europe because their vaccine rollout has
been slow
is going to hit them worse hit britain
less
because of the success so far of our
vaccine program in the circumstances we
now find ourselves in
what would you like the government to do
going forward into spring and early
summer
i think that they should now recognize
that it is a lot more efficient and
effective
for each of us to make our own risk
assessments
because our positions are too different
to allow for anything else
some of us have had the disease but
already some of us have been vaccinated
some of us are young some old some
healthy some not
a one-size-fits-all approach is no
longer
a defensible way of approaching this we
have got
to make a risk assessment for ourselves
and those
immediately around us what would happen
if that then
led to a huge spike in cases
and deaths i think that it's unlikely to
lead to a huge spike
i would certainly accept that it might
lead to a small one but we have to be
prepared to take risks because of the
enormous collateral
costs if even if you simply confine
yourself to the position of the
of the health sector we are looking
at a significant increase in diseases
like dementia and cancer which are also
killers
but actually this isn't just a public
health issue
it's an economic issue it's a moral
issue it's an educational issue it's a
social issue
we've got to face the fact that it may
be worth putting up
with a modest increase in the death toll
in order to be able to have an economy
that functions
an educational system that functions we
simply
have to accept that no country ever
saved lives by making itself poorer
the government though is very influenced
i would suggest by what happened
last summer and into early autumn
by last summer we thought things were
going to open out and we had that eat
out scheme where you were
subsidized go to the local restaurant
things seemed to be beginning to get
back to normal the economy was beginning
to pick up too and then suddenly cases
started
to rise again and death started to rise
again
and the government delayed bringing in
more lockdown
uh procedures then and it's being
accused now
as a result of that increasing deaths
because it was so
slow to act to move in to further
lockdown
isn't that isn't it right that the
government should
take notice of its previous experience
when it didn't go so well
of course but we have to look rather
carefully what its previous experience
was
right from the outset indeed in the
notorious imperial college statistical
projection produced in the middle of
march last year
the government was told that lockdowns
only work
if they are kept in place permanently
until there's a vaccine
so actually the government had a choice
it could say
at last march we will now have a vaccine
a lockdown
that will last for as long as it takes
to get the vaccine
or it might as well forget the lockdown
altogether
because the reality is as the imperial
college study
quite clearly showed is that if you have
a lock down
and then lift it what happens is that
the lives that you've saved
during the lockdown the deaths are
simply shunted
into a later period now i doubt
whether the british people even in their
relatively submissive mood of last year
would have tolerated
the government saying we are going to
lock you all down
for what may be anything up to 18 months
or at least a year but that was the
choice that they had
the reality is that if more people
who were young and healthy had got the
disease
during the summer when they were most
unlikely
these are categories that are most
unlikely to become seriously ill or die
many more of them would have had a
natural immunity
at the time when the more virulent
strains came
in during the autumn i don't think it's
at all clear
that this policy worked
when the lockdown was in force i don't
think it's at all clear
that if the lockdown had been kept
permanently in place
it would have been complied with the
fact is a lockdown can work
if it is one total and two
indefinites in duration and that would
have done
even more catastrophic damage to our
educational sector
and our economy and to the health of
people
in respect of other diseases than what
we have suffered anyway
and yet the british government is not
alone
in not following your advice when it
comes to lockdown
almost every major government in the
democratic world
has been forced into uh lockdowns
various forms of them
politicians governments are very
difficult different political
hues whether it's governor cuomo in new
york
or president macron in france or
chancellor merkel
in germany or whoever was prime minister
back then i can't remember there it's
now mr draghi but back then
whoever was prime minister in italy they
had to do lockdowns too
particularly in the north uh i mean
there has to be
something to the argument that if all
these governments saw that was the right
way
there has to be something in that only
if they were
making an independent judgment in fact
what was happening
is that they were all copying each other
because they were afraid that their own
populations would say
oh look in the country next door they're
doing this why aren't you doing
something similar
the fact is that before the lockdowns
were ordered
all governments that had done serious
studies about this including our own
had a policy based on serious scientific
advice
that they would not lock people down you
can take our example for example and
i'll mention germany in a moment
in this country we had been planning for
an event exactly like this
for more than 10 years it was top of the
national risk register
in 2011 a detailed plan which was kept
regularly up to date was prepared as to
how to deal with it
and the basic principles behind that
plan
were first of all that you did not use
coercion
you used advice to the population
but you allowed them to make their own
risk assessments
and secondly that you did not isolate
or take abrasive measures against the
healthy you concentrated
on isolating the infectious and the sick
now strikingly enough exactly the same
principles lay behind the german
national pandemic plan which was drawn
up
by the robert koch institute which is a
highly respected body
they all those that have published plans
worked along exactly the same lines and
the world health organization
also recommended exactly that approach
so what we have here is governments
independently
forming the view that they should take a
less abrasive attitude to major
pandemics
and then all copying each other and
throwing out the window
10 years worth of careful scientific and
administrative planning
that does not do credit to any of these
governments
they basically jettisoned their own
research
now i've heard it said that nobody
expected
that there would be any pandemic
anything like as serious as this
i'm afraid that is simply untrue the
2017 edition of the national risk
register in this country
envisaged that a new pathogen might
cause deaths up to 750
000 not even professor ferguson has
suggested that the deaths
would have been anything like that on
any of the various hypotheses
so what we have actually done is to
reject the scientific approach
to adopt a policy that fails to
discriminate between different degrees
of vulnerability
and that is scientifically disreputable
the reason why this is happening
is the fear of populations across europe
and their belief that if their
governments are not doing something
abrasive and hyperactive about it
they are going to sleep on the job
that's never been true
they they had very careful plans and
they should have adhered to them
final question for you do you see a link
as some do
a link between a government that has now
presided over
a variety of lockdowns for a year now
and this new policing bill which would
seem
to in various ways crib and confine
our ability to protest and demonstrate
peacefully
i don't see much of a link i think
there's a good deal of
uh of press reporting to suggest
and it sounds plausible that the home
secretary was much exercised by protests
against the lockdown and
if that is true then it may well be that
there is a link but actually the issues
raised
in the current bill have been around for
a long time
parts of the bill are perfectly
acceptable in my view and parts of it
are not
the bits that aren't acceptable are the
bits that give an altogether excessive
discretion
to both the police and the home
secretary we ought not to have laws that
are defined entirely by the home
secretary
who is now under this bill it's proposed
to give her powers
to say it's to say what constitutes
sufficient disruption to constitute a
criminal offence
we ought not to allow policemen on the
hoof
to decide which protests they will
curtail
and which they will not on the other
hand other parts of the bill
are perfectly respectable because it
seems to me that a person's right to
protest
stops short at the point when they have
to trample on other people's rights to
go about their ordinary business
and the creation of a a public nuisance
offence seems to me to be a desirable
and healthy
step john consumption thank you for that
thank you for joining us on spectator tv
[Music]
pleasure
[Music]
you